since you were last here we started a
new segment called ask a desk spurt i
did it again
i said sheesh
um
and you started a fabulous new podcast
dear chelsea where you give advice
um to people
and so we wanted to combine the two and
get you to give some advice so it's time
for ask a desperate
and
we like to say we're not experts we're
desk perts oh we did it
um and we love trying to uh just get
involved in your business basically
um so let's kick it off with samantha
mazuna um who is here today hello
samantha how are you and what is your
dilemma hi
um so i'm having a halloween party for
the first time and i need some advice
i'm a part of a few different friend
groups and i really want to have
everyone at my party but two people
don't really get along what should i do
should i invite one and not the other
oh
i would say my personal opinion is that
you invite everybody and tell everybody
this isn't about you this is about
halloween and enjoying that
[Applause]
i agree i think you have to say listen i
want you all there but there's a heads
up they're going to be there and don't
come unless you can be cool right
yeah that's good advice for everybody
anyway
that is the best uh advice because i was
and what you said too because i was
gonna say tell them all to grow up um
but that's not very helpful advising
someone they're gonna be there and if
they can handle it great if they can't
skip it
yeah problem solved yeah perfect you're
welcome
absolutely and you look so pretty thank
you
it's for you guys i love your top you
are giving it thank you
a litter makeup thank you they have to
touch my eyebrows or they're not good
enough nails i love it i'm picking up
what you're putting down turquoise rings
hello oh of course turquoise rings
always okay okay see you at the party
girl you don't need fashion advice
that's for sure ross you're back all
right up next we got a question from
krista on twitter uh she writes i'm
getting married soon and my fiance wants
to invite all his little nieces to the
reception i'm not totally on board with
this should kids be invited to weddings
i mean it is no i you know how i feel
about kids i could really take them or
leave them in fact
but uh
man it is her fiance so he should have a
say in who he has at the wedding right
yes i mean out of respect for your
relationship it would be nice to be to
compromise yes
yeah but i
my thought is um it age is important um
are you know are they two or three or
four or five because two or three you
anyone parents here raise your hands
there are certain ages where they're
just you know they're not going to
listen to what you're saying
um so age is important uh meeting your
man in the middle and then also uh you
can do a little area at the reset say
maybe not during the ceremony so it's
not distracting but at the party
afterwards you can have them and then
you also have a little pillow area with
like a little movie
going on so they can participate but
maybe not distract from the ceremony if
they're too young that's a good idea
yeah or get a bounce house and just
throw them all in there
um okay we have one more conundrum
coming in from zoom
alley canal
how can we help hi guys okay so i am 28
years old i've been with my boyfriend
for nearly eight years now we do not
live together we are not close to
getting married but i am at the age
where a lot of my friends they're
starting to shack up with their
boyfriends or even get engaged and
they've been together half the amount of
time as i've been with my boyfriend so
how do i stop myself from comparing my
own relationship timeline to other
people's
oh
yeah you can't measure your own
experience against the experience of
your friends i mean if you've been in a
relationship for eight years and you
really want to be married and living
with your partner then that's a more
serious conversation that you have to
have with him but please don't compare
yourself to other people it does not
matter what other people are doing you
have to be honest with your relationship
and where you're at and if you're in
love with your guy and the feelings are
mutual and you're being respected then
that's really more valuable than
anyone's wedding day yeah mm-hmm
and
agree
also
you know if you're you feel like you're
getting frustrated at your friends
because they're getting engaged so
quickly maybe like refocus where that
frustration is are you frustrated in
your own situation
maybe ask yourself that question too in
terms of like
are you feeling pressure from other
people for a timeline are you putting a
timeline on yourself can you do what
chelsea said and sort of relieve
yourself of that pressure
i agree i do think i let other the
pressure of you know parents
grandparents they're like when are you
getting engaged what's the deal here so
but i agree i'm not ready to get married
i'm not in a rush to move in so i think
i just got to take a step step back i
like that thank you
um i i really think the most important
question no matter what you do on this
journey is are you happy is he nice to
you on a daily basis is there kindness
in this relationship
those are
that is the most important question and
if you have that then it doesn't matter
what anyone else is doing around you
yeah if you guys are good to each other
that is issue number one for me agreed
and be happy for your friends
okay that's all i have to say
thank you good luck to you
i can't wait to see where this story
goes and
chelsea i cannot wait i am so excited
chelsea handler at the beacon theater i
can't think of a more potent combination
our vaccinated and
ready for action tour
is uh go to our website and chelsea's
website to get dates and tours and
cities and all the information and um i
can't wait i can't wait either thank you
guys
[Applause]
[Music]
you